Courtney Cox has to use the left Oppel  ganger okay no need to panic  deep breaths everyone the famous  comparison being Caitlyn Jenner and the  Fred star is embracing it on Thursday  Courtney posed for this selfie with  comedian David Spade and former bachelor  Nick file after David shared the snap  fans immediately called out the  resemblance between Courtney and Caitlyn  that was incredible actress couldn't  help a poke fun at it by posting a slide  show the first photo was the original  group shot which Courtney followed up  with a screen shot of several comments  pointing out how similar she looks to  Caitlyn and capping it off with a  side-by-side of her and Caitlyn that  says alright I can see it her friends  co-star Jennifer Aniston couldn't help  but laugh commenting you're hilarious oh  my god I love you Caitlyn has yet to  comment on her new doppelganger status  but we're guessing she'd take it as the  ultimate compliment  [Music]  you